NEW DETAILS
ABOUT THE CLASSIFIED MATERIALS
FOUND AT PRESIDENT BIDEN'S HOME
AND THE FALLOUT.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW THIS
MORNING.
THE WHITE HOUSE CONFIRMS THE
AIDES FOUND FIVE ADDITIONAL
PAGES OF CLASSIFIED MATERIALS ON
THE SAME DAY A SPECIAL COUNSEL
WAS APPOINTED TO INVESTIGATE THE
MATTER.
THAT BRINGS A TOTAL OF DOCUMENTS
RECOVERED TO ABOUT 20.
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNCIL'S OFFICE
ANNOUNCING IT WILL NO LONGER
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
CONTROVERSY BECAUSE OF A SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION UNDER WAY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S PERSONAL
ATTORNEYS SAY THEY HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO BALANCE THE IMPORTANCE
OF PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY WITH
PROTECTING THE INTEGRITY OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT BEEN
TRANSPARENT ENOUGH FOR JAMES
COMER.
HE'S DEMANDING MORE INFORMATION
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY YET
WHETHER THEY BROKE THE LAW OR
NOT.
I WILL ACCUSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OF NOT BEING
TRANSPARENT.
WHY DIDN'T WE HEAR ABOUT THIS ON
NOVEMBER 2nd WHEN THE FIRST
BATCH OF CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
WERE DISCOVERED.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE COMING TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S DEFENSE
DETERMINED TO HIGHLIGHT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BIDEN'S
HANDLING OF CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
AND TRUMP'S.
>> WE WERE DELIGHTED TO LEARN
THAT THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS,
THE MOMENT THEY FOUND OUT ABOUT
THE DOCUMENTS THAT DAY TURNED
THEM OVER TO THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES AND ULTIMATELY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THAT IS A VERY DIFFERENT POSTURE
THAN WHAT WE SAW WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
>> SO LET'S BRING IN CNN SENIOR
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT, MJ
LEE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
LOOK, THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BUT
IF YOU'RE EXPLAINING, YOU'RE
LOSING.
BECAUSE OVER THE WEEKEND WE GOT
ANOTHER UPDATE OF MORE DOCUMENTS
BEING FOUND.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING, DON,
YET ANOTHER UPDATE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNCIL'S OFFICE
OVER THE WEEKEND ABOUT MORE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
FOUND THAT WE WEREN'T PREVIOUSLY
AWARE OF.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT FIVE
ADDITIONAL PAGES OF CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE FOUND AT
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S WILMINGTON
HOME ON THURSDAY NIGHT.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO THE PRESIDENT.
HE SAYS HE WENT OVER TO THE
WILMINGTON HOUSE WITH DOJ
OFFICIALS TO HAND OVER ONE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENT THAT HAD
BEEN DISCOVERED ON WEDNESDAY AND
IT IS AT THIS POINT THAT THIS
GROUP DISCOVERED THE ADDITIONAL
PAGES WITH CLASSIFIED MARKINGS.
NOW HE SAID THAT THE DOJ
IMMEDIATELY TOOK OVER THOSE
DOCUMENTS AND THAT NOW THAT A
SPECIAL COUNSEL HAS BEEN
APPOINTED TO INVESTIGATE THIS
MATTER, THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNCIL'S OFFICE IS NO LONGER
GOING TO BE ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
>> AND THE PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL
LAWYER PUT OUT THIS LENGTHY
STATEMENT OVER THE WEEKEND
TRYING TO DEFEND HOW EVERYTHING
HAS BEEN HANDLED SO FAR.
THAT'S KIND OF TRICKY AGAIN SO
MANY DETAILS.
I'M NOT SURE IF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN PARSE THE DETAILS.
I'M SURE THEY KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, MJ, ONE PERSON HAD
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE MISHANDLES,
ANOTHER PERSON HAD DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE HIS MISHANDLED AND
MAYBE THAT'S HOW THE PUBLIC SEES
IT BUT WHAT ARE THE LAWYERS
SAYING?
>> WE'RE SEEING THE WHITE HOUSE
PLAY DEFENSE RIGHT NOW.
THE PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL LAWYER,
BOB BAUER PUT OUT A LENGTHY
STATEMENT OVER THE WEEKEND
EXPLAINING THE DIFFERENT
PROCESSES THAT THE LAWYERS
AROUND THE PRESIDENT HAVE
FOLLOWED THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
AND PARTICULARLY EXPLAINING WHY
LAWYERS COULDN'T REALLY DISCLOSE
ALL OF THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
KNEW AT ANY GIVEN TIME FOR FEAR
OF INTERFERING WITH AN ONGOING
DOJ REVIEW.
I WANT TO READ A KEY PART OF
THAT STATEMENT FROM BOB BAUER
THAT I THINK TRIES TO EXPLAIN A
MAJOR PART OF THIS PROCESS.
HE SAYS, BECAUSE PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S PERSONAL LAWYERS DO NOT
HAVE ACTIVE SECURITY CLEARANCES,
WHENEVER A DOCUMENT BEARING
CLASSIFIED MARKINGS WAS
IDENTIFIED, THE SEARCH WAS
SUSPENDED OF THE BOX, FILE, OR
OTHER SPACE WHERE THE DOCUMENT
WAS DISCOVERED WITH THE
POTENTIALLY CLASSIFIED MATERIAL
LEFT IN THE PLACE AS FOUND.
NOW HE SAYS THE GOVERNMENT WAS
PROMPTLY NOTIFIED.
IT'S FOR THIS REASON THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL ATTORNEYS
DO NOT KNOW THE PRECISE NUMBER
OF PAGES IN THE DISCOVERED
MATERIAL NOR HAVE THEY REVIEWED
THE CONTENT OF THE DOCUMENTS
CONSISTENT WITH THE STANDARD
PROCEDURES AND REQUIREMENTS.
NOW THE WHITE HOUSE HAS FACED A
TON OF QUESTIONS ABOUT BOTH THE
MESSAGING AND THE TRANSPARENCY.
I THINK WHAT WE CAN SAY WITH
CERTAINTY RIGHT NOW IS IT IS
VERY POSSIBLE IN THE COMING DAYS
AND WEEKS WE COULD BE LEARNING
ABOUT ADDITIONAL CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW.
>> MJ LEE AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
THANK YOU.
>>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS WITH
RONALD HEIR.
GOOD MORNING, SIR, THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
>> GOOD MORNING, GLAD TO BE
HERE.
>> WE WERE STRUCK -- THANKS FOR
COMING ON BECAUSE WE WERE STRUCK
BY TWO OP-EDS IN TWO DAYS IN TWO
DIFFERENT PUBLICATIONS ONE WAS
YOURS IN THE ATLANTIC.
THE TITLE IS BIDEN'S CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS SHOULD HAVE NO IMPACT
ON TRUMP'S LEGAL JEOPARDY AND
THIS PIECE IN "THE WASHINGTON
POST."
IF MAR-A-LAGO CASE COLLAPSES,
A -- DISASTER DODGED, AMERICA.
IT GOES ON TO SAY, ACCORDING TO
THE LATEST DATA, 45% OF
AMERICANS IDENTIFY AS
REPUBLICANS OR LEANING TOWARDS
REPUBLICANS 44% DEMOCRAT OR LEAN
IN THAT DIRECTION.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SERVES
THEM ALL AND ITS CREDIBILITY
RESTS ON BEING PERCEIVED TO PLAY
FAIR.
YOU WROTE IN YOUR PIECE ONE OF
THE MOST SUPERFICIAL PARALLELS.
ONLY THE MOST SUPERFICIAL
PARALLELS CAN BE DRAWN BETWEEN
THE TWO.
I WONDER, DONALD, IF YOU THINK
IN THE EYES OF THE PUBLIC THESE
CASES ARE INEXTRICABLY LINKED?
>> THAT'S WHY WE WROTE THE
ARTICLE WE WROTE, IS BECAUSE
IT'S CERTAINLY TRUE THAT WHEN
YOU HAVE TWO PRESIDENTS, ONE
CURRENT AND ONE PAST, WHO BOTH
HAVE, YOU KNOW, IT'S FAIR TO SAY
THEIR TEAMS AND THEM PERHAPS
HAVE MISHANDLED CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT CONDUCT IS AT
ISSUE.
AND AS FAR AS WE KNOW NOW, AS
YOU JUST ACCOUNTED, THE BIDEN
PEOPLE CLEARLY MADE A BLUNDER IN
HAVING THESE DOCUMENTS TAKEN
AND -- TAKEN AWAY FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THERE'S NO TWO WAYS ABOUT THAT,
BUT IT APPEARS FROM WHAT WE SEE,
AND TIME WILL TELL IF IT'S TRUE.
IT APPEARS THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
INTEREST IN CONCEALING THESE
DOCUMENTS THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO
KEEP THESE DOCUMENTS.
THEY'RE AS EAGER AS ANYBODY TO
GET THEM BACK TO WHERE THEY
BELONG IN THE GOVERNMENT.
AND TRUMP'S TEAM, AND TRUMP
HIMSELF, IT APPEARS FROM THE
EVIDENCE, HAVE ACTIVELY BEEN
ENGAGED IN FIGURING OUT WAYS TO
NOT GIVE THEM BACK OVER A PERIOD
OF MANY, MANY MONTHS.
IT'S THAT INTENTIONAL
CONCEALMENT AND OBSTRUCTION THAT
GIVES RISE TO CRIMINAL POSSIBLE
PROSECUTION.
AND THAT'S THE KEY DIFFERENCE
HERE.
SO I THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND, ESSENTIALLY, THE
CRITICAL DIFFERENCE, WHY IT
MATTERS TO HAVE A FORMER
PRESIDENT DELIBERATELY KEEPING
AND CONCEALING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION OF THE HIGHEST
SENSITIVITY, AND I THINK MERRICK
GARLAND, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
HAS ACTUALLY HANDLED IT QUITE
WELL BY APPOINTING SPECIAL
COUNSELS.
BECAUSE, CLEARLY, THERE ARE
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO ARE GOING
TO SAY, EVEN THOUGH I DON'T
THINK IT'S FAIR, AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S JUSTIFIED.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING
TO SAY, OH, MERRICK GARLAND,
WORKS FOR JOE BIDEN, SO MERRICK
GARLAND IS IN THE TANK AND HE'LL
DO WHATEVER JOE BIDEN WANTS.
NOT TRUE.
BUT MUCH BETTER TO HAVE SOMEONE
WHO'S ACTUALLY AN EXCELLENT
LAWYER BUT ALSO A TRUMP
APPOINTEE LOOKING AT THE BIDEN
SITUATION.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE ARE NOW
AND I HOPE PEOPLE CAN LEARN FROM
IT.
>> THAT WAS REALLY BACK-TO-BACK
AS IT PERTAINS TO THE BIDEN
DOCUMENTS MERRICK GARLAND WENT
OUT OF HIS WAY TO MAKE SURE IT
WAS TRUMP APPOINTEES, FIRST OUT
OF CHICAGO AND NOW THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, A TRUMP APPOINTEE AS
WELL.
>> I WONDER, THE CHAIR OF THE
HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, JAMES
COMER SAYS SUBPOENAS ARE ON THE
TABLE FOR THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
IN THIS CASE.
IF THAT HAPPENS, YOU WORKED IN
THIS WHITE HOUSE, YOU WORKED
UNDER TWO REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATIONS BUT IF YOU
WORKED IN THIS WHITE HOUSE, WHAT
WOULD YOUR ADVICE BE?
>> I THINK IT'S CLEARLY
INAPPROPRIATE FOR CONGRESS TO BE
INVESTIGATING AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION -- AN ONGOING
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
THEY CAN LOOK AT IT AFTER IT
OCCURS, BUT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
RIGHT.
IT'S REALLY A SEPARATION OF
POWERS VIOLATION, TO COME IN IN
THE MIDDLE OF AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION AND TRY TO DISRUPT
IT BY -- I GUESS WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO IS MAKE PUBLIC WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE INVESTIGATION.
ONE OF THE VERY SACRED THINGS
ABOUT OUR CRIMINAL PROCESS AND
THE INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ENGAGES IN IS THAT IT'S NOT
SUPPOSED TO PUBLICALLY PILLAR
PEOPLE OR FACTS THAT ARE UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
THE JOB IS TO INVESTIGATE,
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE FACTS ARE,
FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S A CASE TO
BE BROUGHT AND THEN BRING IT AND
TALK ABOUT IT.
BUT YOU DON'T DO IT WHILE YOU'RE
INVESTIGATING.
SO I THINK ONE WOULD RESIST THE
SUBPOENAS WITH REGARD TO THE
ONGOING CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
>> SO YOU THINK McCARTHY IS
WRONG WHEN HE SAID YESTERDAY ON
FOX NEWS THERE'S AN OBLIGATION
FOR CONGRESS TO DO THIS NOW?
>> YEAH, WELL, I THINK CERTAINLY
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO DO
OVERSIGHT, CERTAINLY, OF WHAT
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH IS DOING.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO
GET INTO THE SPECIFICS OF AN
ONGOING CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
I'M AFRAID WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE IS, YOU KNOW, REALLY AN
EFFORT THAT'S ENTIRELY AIMED --
TALK ABOUT POLITICIZATION.
IT'S ENTIRELY AIMED AT TRYING TO
POLITICIZE THE SITUATION IN A
WAY THEY BELIEVE WILL APPEAL TO
FAR RIGHT MAGA REPUBLICAN
SUPPORTERS AND THEY WANT TO STIR
UP THAT POT AND IT'S REGRETTABLE
BECAUSE THIS COUNTRY DOESN'T
NEED TO HAVE CONTROVERSY AND
CONFLICT STIRRED UP ANY MORE AT
THIS POINT.
>> DONALD AYERS THANK YOU FOR
TIME THIS MORNING.